[Music]
all right people of the internet welcome
to another reuben report friday round
table extravaganza
today we're going to be talking about
trump's lawsuit against big tech
tucker carlson accusing the nsa of
spying on him
and critical race theory he didn't think
we could do a day without critical race
theory
uh now fully infiltrating public schools
in america my
three guests are writer of up in the air
thumb sucker and blood will out walter
kern
the world's most famous knitting trump
supporter dr
carlin borisenko and my favorite
canadian lawyer turned youtuber
viva fray welcome to the reuben report
everybody
how's it going dave thank you it is
going well it's good to be with you guys
i'm looking forward to this panel
uh let's get right into it uh trump
is suing the twitter and the youtube and
the google
and the whole damn thing since we're
streaming this on youtube right now i
feel like that should be the lead story
uh let's take a look at what donald
trump has got to say
i just want to say that i stand before
you
this morning to announce a very
important
and very beautiful i think development
for
our freedom and our freedom of speech
and that goes to all americans
today in conjunction with the america
first
policy institute i'm filing as the
lead class representative a major class
action lawsuit against
the big tech giants including facebook
google and twitter
as well as their ceos mark zuckerberg
sunder boucher and jack
dorsey three real nice guys
we're asking the u.s district court for
the southern district of florida to
order an immediate
halt to social media companies
illegal shameful censorship of
the american people and that's exactly
what they are doing
all right class action lawsuit with
trump at the head of this thing
viva you're the lawyer i know you're
canadian
but you have a good handle on what's
happening here in america i mean does he
have a chance with this thing
so i preface that by the fact that i'm a
canadian lawyer so
what i've learned from the american law
is self-taught
and also learned from the best minds in
american law dershowitz barnes
brody the other youtube lawyers i want
this lawsuit to succeed
but i am exquisitely skeptical that it
is going to as drafted
basically the argument that trump is
raising at the very least against
twitter
is that they have become basically de
facto state actors
because of their working in concert or
at the direction of or under the
coercion of
state actors the problem is just as a
pure matter of fact as drafted
the allegations the factual allegations
to support that argument
seem thin at best and robert f kennedy
junior's lawsuit against facebook which
alleged a similar sort of
state actor caution working in tandem
just failed as well
so this is probably going to fail at the
lower levels and maybe succeed at the
higher levels but
i'm still skeptical despite all the
optimism i want to hold
yeah that's interesting because i
actually saw an interview with
dershowitz
uh yesterday on newsmax and he had a
similar take
basically he was like look this actually
might be
the biggest free speech lawsuit in
modern times but it may not work at the
lower courts but he thinks this thing
could get to the supreme court
walter you usually have a good sort of
blue sky broad view of what's going on
in the country what do you make of this
thing is this publicity by trump do you
think there's some real teeth to it
well trump sues people probably five
times a day and
he does it and he does it for all kinds
of things
he doesn't necessarily do it to win uh
he does it
to raise issues and and it's all
important whether this succeeds or not
to realize
that twitter has gained near
monopoly power on a certain kind of
online
live conversation um they've privatized
online conversation and then they've uh
fenced it around with rules that are
impossible to understand trump was
kicked off for
supposedly inciting violence they don't
tell you what inciting is they don't
yeah you know and so it reminds me of
twitter reminds me of one of those towns
that
has a thousand laws that it only uh
enforces when they don't like you and
and so you know he's bringing up a fact
that might not be a matter of law but is
a real one
where are we to converse they take out
the other apps
you know they make it almost impossible
for a twitter competitor to really be
robust
so whether he wins or not doesn't matter
to me americans need to
see that uh
these places are not going to be
the final arbiters of how we speak and
especially about public issues
if trump was a porn star you know and
was well
if he was a porn star he'd still be on
there
right exactly carlin
that is the irony that oh sorry dave go
ahead no no viva go ahead
i was just gonna say that is the irony
one of the issues that trump raises in
the lawsuit which in my view has nothing
to do with the lawsuit
is the the explicit child exploitation
content
that is still on twitter so they ban
trump for talking about peaceful
protests because it incites violence
and then they allow a bunch of other
objectively
uh unconscionable if not outright
illegal content to remain up there
he is starting a discussion and we'll
see where the discussion goes right i
think that's the key part here which is
what walter is hitting on that it may
not be about the lawsuit he sues an
awful lot of people and he loses plenty
of lawsuits i mean he lost the election
lawsuits
but what could be unearthed maybe in
discovery if these guys have to open up
some of the books and show some of the
policies
and the inconsistencies and everything
else even if the lawsuit doesn't work
just bringing the attention to it might
be good carlin you've like the rest of
us you've been shadow band you've lost
followers
i think you've been temporarily
suspended from things at times and had
facebook things disappear i assume you
basically like the idea at least of what
trump's doing here right
well i actually really liked the idea
and actually this is kind of a personal
issue for me because i'm involved with
the walk away campaign and after january
6
walkaways facebook group was completely
banned off of facebook for
no good reason but what a lot of people
don't know is that
not only was the walk away facebook
group banned but every single admin had
their personal accounts banned so we're
talking just average everyday people
like merchandise managers or people that
work for walk away
who are running businesses on facebook
those businesses got completely
destroyed
so the walk away campaign is actually a
part of this class action lawsuit
and i'm excited to see where it goes do
you guys
think that if these things just blew up
just meaning if what happened to parlor
just somehow happened to them
that we would just be much better off
as a species viva well
i say twitter is the the you know the
dark hole of the internet it's a place
where people are angry they go to vent
their anger
but it is a place where information is
exchanged where real-time information is
exchanged
i i don't know what the solution is
there is a very very big problem because
twitter clearly has a monopoly google
and youtube clearly have a monopoly and
they are clearly
censoring based on ideological
perspectives
um how do you go about solving this
problem
i think you have to find a better
argument i'm not sure that the state
actor is going to be the working
argument this time
but it will start a discussion by the
time trump runs again in 2024
this will have worked its way through
the courts and either been shut down
or approved probably shut down in which
case it becomes an election campaign
issue
uh but people need to start realizing
this and they only do realize that once
they start getting banned themselves
despite not being on one side of the
political aisle yeah walter what do you
think just in terms of just the general
health of society if these things just
disappeared i mean one of the reasons
i'm usually not for regulating them i
i'm sort of for breaking them up i think
at this point
but the reason i don't like the
regulation ideas to me that just makes
sure that they're always going to exist
as that public square and as you said
they've sort of privatized the public
square
well well they aren't the public square
in the pa
in the real public squares of the world
people stand with signs
saying the messiah is coming repent
people swear and rant and rave
what they are is a engineered
discourse environment see what twitter
does really is not allow you to freely
speak and then just compile
they engineer the uh responses
they uh invite in by armies that push
away
certain ideas and applaud others it's a
it's a a manufactured uh
a manufactured event twitter it's like
an audience for play
in which everyone's secretly working for
the playwright
and some people's job is to laugh at
other people
and and so maintaining that controlled
environment
that sort of artificial uh dome
of discourse is very hard for them and
one thing trump did
that they don't like is that he kind of
blows it up when he goes on there
um you know he's the lenny bruce of
american politics his job is to say
the unsayable and and that is his great
value to us
in fact yeah carlin um since you've been
through the shadow banning and all the
other stuff does it seem like it's
gotten weirder to you in the last couple
weeks
this is a little insider baseball but
i've noticed for example when i tweet
things out now
like the first 50 responses will all be
how much people hate me and all this
nonsense and then i always have to click
see more to see then hundreds of people
who are saying nice things
so they've created a situation where
they're depending on what political
allegiance you have or whatever your
beliefs are they can decide who's going
to show you the nice stuff who you're
gonna see that's you know nice and
positive
and just reorganize things i mean i
think that's walter's point
yeah i mean dave your first mistake
there was reading the comments in
general you never read the comments on
twitter
but no i mean listen i gotta strike on
my youtube channel for being a
psychologist who read a peer-reviewed
psychology article about the
psychological impact of mass
i was banned on facebook for like four
days for quoting the new york times
it's absolutely ridiculous there's no
rhyme or reason to how they apply these
things
and you know i think people are starting
to wake up to just how artificial the
entire environment is
there is a ryman reason and we just
don't know what it is
well the rage the rage clicks are
definitely what they're after there's no
question about that so the algorithm is
driven by interactions and negative
interactions
are more prevalent and more heated than
positive interactions but
to what walter said about this not being
the public square i i think these ideas
are not mutually exclusive i think it is
the public square even if it is geared
towards profit for the for the
enterprise but i
i and that's where i think like this has
to be regarded as a public square
or something of a utility and when you
have government officials using it
to convey emergency measures emergency
uh emergency tweets information
then i think it has to be treated as a
utility and it can't be
shut down or turned off because of what
some people are saying on it
saving except for that which is
officially illegal already
but uh no no question negativity uh is
definitely the driving force
on twitter walter would you what do you
think about that argument because i
think that's pretty compelling even
though at the same time we could all
close our accounts and walk off tomorrow
and we'd still be okay yeah i mean we
could all shut up and lock ourselves in
the back room and wait
for the next 50 years of history to pass
and that might be a good option because
it's getting darker
but you know uh i i don't know quite
what the argument was essentially i mean
say it again
that it has effectively become a utility
in that it's not just
a private company government officials
use it to convey
politics messages emergency messages
they use it as a utility in
as much as you know the public horn
system in the netherlands to warn people
people of a flood or something
so it is more of a utility and a public
square officially than it is a private
company
and i think in that sense govern it the
way you would govern cell phone carriers
water supplies although uh dave in
california they are shutting off
electricity
if they don't like what you're doing but
um i i say treat it that way that's the
stronger argument
to to end the sort of censorship but i
don't think it's been fully fleshed out
in the courts yet
the thing is as you alluded to earlier
dave there are
a lot of uh forms of manipulation
censorship
and uh sort of uh behavior modification
that aren't just banning someone from
twitter i mean
uh i've begun to be able to read
what twitter is doing with my account
from week to week and
you say it's been weird recently and it
it does get weird at times
there are times when people don't see
your tweets there are people uh
who you know really subscribe to your
twitter feed
who suddenly don't and then they get it
back there are times when you lose and
gain
followers for mysterious reasons you
feel
like you're a lab rat in twitter and
these people in white coats that you
can't see
are constantly changing the you know the
food
and putting in water over there and
closing off this part of the maze
and uh so if it's a
if it's a public square then it should
not be allowed
to bring fake and artificial people into
the public square
to constantly make it seem that things
are happening that are not
i mean uh the worst thing isn't just
that they ban people
it's that they promote fake people yeah
uh fate
that aren't people right yeah exactly
and just to put to put a button on this
one it's like not only could
could we all walk but the strangest
thing with twitter and facebook and
everything else is they have so much
ubiquitous power over our lives
and it's like you can't get anyone on
the phone from any of these companies we
all have gmail
has anyone ever spoke to someone from
gmail on the phone has anyone ever spoke
to someone from facebook
twitter i mean i'm pretty well connected
guy i can't get anyone on the phone
or any representative to talk to anybody
so uh
maybe they are a little too big but
speaking of a little too big
the second story is this really really
bizarre story
uh that started it kicked off last week
when tucker carlson
accused the nsa of spying on him because
uh
information was leaked that he said
could only have been leaked
from his private email we've got a
little more on that
last week last monday we told you that
the biden administration's
largest intelligence gathering agency
the nsa
had been reading my private emails even
saying that out loud is weird it's one
of those segments we never thought we
would do
ever but the country has changed that
much that fast and honestly the whole
thing was kind of shocking
the government was spying on us come on
it seemed crazy
but it's true and no one in washington
appeared to be shocked in the slightest
in fact the usual shills right after our
segment had a ready explanation for
it either it never happened at all they
said just a cable news show lying for
ratings
or there must have been a good reason it
happened and they began
furiously making excuses for the nsa did
it a powerful heavily politicized spy
agencies surveilling journalists who've
been critical of the regime
no problem it's perfectly normal just
don't call it spying
but it's not normal at all it is third
world
and as we told you repeatedly it did
happen now that has been
confirmed all right so just to clarify
tucker had reached out to kremlin
contacts about getting an interview with
putin
tucker is a journalist he interviews
people that's what they do
uh walter it seems like most of media is
just like yeah big damn whoop he
shouldn't have reached out or
or he's a russian operative i mean just
the usual nonsense
that we've gotten you know over the last
four or five years
yeah well okay here's the thing about
this story
um the nsa loves it the nsa
despite the sometimes seeming like the
bad guy
loves the message that yep
we can do anything to anyone at any time
and we don't have to be candid about it
they let tucker
they let tucker make the accusation they
then let him be
called a liar they then didn't interfere
when it turns out to be true
and you know we see that the thing he
was being spied for
was trying to get an interview with one
of the other
maybe two world leaders who are run a
great nuclear power
i mean what is what is more legitimate
journalism
than trying to interview you know putin
they make it sound as though he was
doing a dead drop in force
marcy park you know trying to uh pass
microfilm my god he was trying to get an
interview with a world leader
yeah you know what is totally
flabbergasting about all this i have
never seen in unison so many
certified blue check marks on twitter
mainstream media
run to the defense of the nsa i don't
want to have these conspiratorial
thoughts
like they must the media must be working
with intelligence
it's either that or they're absolute
ignorant
and have totally forgotten about the
largest illegal
domestic surveillance program that the
nsa was carrying out
a few years ago a decade ago and they
pretend now that that could never happen
again and
certainly if it does happen they've made
a carve out for fox news and tucker
carlson
i've never seen such willful blindness
or deliberate misinformation
from the mainstream media all running
cover for the nsa given the nsa's
history but viva
let's not forget who who was the guy
that was in charge of the nsa when he
was under oath and they asked him if
we're spying on americans and he said
not
wittingly as he was scratching the top
of his head which is a tip-off from
seinfeld who is the guy
who was that does anyone remember he
works for cnn now
yeah i mean he works for cnn
yeah yeah you are not required to be
this is not a conspiracy no one's hiding
it that's why i say they loves it
the nsa loves having its former director
on cnn
it loves taking the largest
cable news personality in the world and
making him
sit in the hot seat while it you know
doesn't you know that's for me to know
and you to find out we're the nsa
carlin is that the broad is that like
the real stamp on this thing right there
that they can just do it in front of us
there's nothing tucker can do there's
nothing the rest of us can do and as
viva says
we can also just have a bunch of blue
check journalists
that uh basically applaud them for it
well i mean listen walter has just
scared the heck out of me because i'm
100
sure he's correct that the nsa is loving
this entire thing and i think it just
goes so it says so much about
how far the divisions in this world have
gone where you know people who maybe 10
years ago would have been completely
against any of this nonsense are now
like
well it's okay as long as it's directed
at my political opponents
like people have forgotten what the
slippery slope is and what it means if
they can do it to your political
opponents that means they can do it to
you
right the lefties were pretty upset when
snowden was leaking all of the stuff
about what the government was doing
somehow they care a little bit less
when it's tucker uh we got one more for
you i know we're a little bit of a time
crunch here
but randy weingarten who's the president
of the teachers union and she is a real
piece of work uh she gave a speech about
critical race theory whether they're
teaching it or not or whether they plan
to teach or not or how important it is
or isn't
let's take a look critical race theory
is not taught in elementary schools
or middle schools or high schools
it's a method of examination taught
in law school and in college
that helps analyze whether systemic
racism exists and in particular
whether it has an effect on law and
public
policy
but cultural warriors are labeling
any discussion of race
racism or discrimination scrt
to try to make it toxic they are
bullying teachers
and trying to stop us from teaching
students accurate history
okay on one hand she's telling us it's
not taught and then she's also telling
us that the people trying to stop it
are trying to stop the truth from being
taught so
little inconsistency there i mean she is
an extraordinary
liar the idea that cultural warriors
are doing this to stop any honest
assessment of race or racism be taught
is complete nonsense
the new meme that they have is oh they
don't want anyone to discuss race or
anything like that we all know that's
not true i have no doubt that everyone
in these four little boxes here was
taught about racism and slavery
and mlk and jim crow laws and everything
else
carlin you've been like at the lead
fight against this thing
um randy widegarten go
yeah i mean she's absolutely lying and
if anyone has any questions about this i
actually on my youtube channel right now
have a recording of an eighth grade
class
in which they were teaching critical
race theories so i have it on video i
know exactly how it's being taught
now the problem is that they are not
teaching critical race theory in k-12
schools in the same way that they're
teaching it in colleges and universities
so what they do in k-12 schools is they
just get little nuggets in there they
like what they did in this eighth grade
class is they said if you agree with the
pledge of allegiance and you want
society to be fair and just
then you need to believe in equity
versus equality because we want everyone
to have the same outcomes
they just plant these little nuggets all
the way through the educational
experience so they're primed when they
go to college
but i'll tell you this too one of the
state bill i worked on the state bill in
new hampshire that was
unfortunately watered down by my rhino
governor chris sununu but before it was
watered down it actually had a provision
in it that said
you can teach every concept in this bill
you just have to teach it from an
objective
fashion you cannot be an activist you
cannot teach things as factually true
that are not factually true and so the
teachers unions are not telling the
truth about these bills
and what they cover you can still teach
about slavery you can still teach about
the holocaust these are just downright
lies
right it's just extraordinary we're not
teaching it and also it must be taught
uh viva i think you saw the op-ed piece
in the times a couple days ago by david
french and a bunch of other people
basically saying that these anti-crt
laws that certain states are passing are
bad ideas
um but to me uh we don't teach nazism
right we don't teach everyone to be
nazis you know what we say on my channel
with robert barnes
confession through projection and you
watch what she just said there
half of it is pure projection in the
idea of trying to bully people into
silence
and demonize discourse that is i say
this from an
absolute outsider's perspective i have
seen the evolution of crt
in the united states over the last two
years what she described as what the
adversaries are trying to do to her is
exactly what they are trying to do
to anybody who oppose crt in schooling
and
her double speak that we don't teach it
in
in
elementary school or whatever but it's
taught in universities well
they give it another word in
universities but they're we've seen it
now
and we've seen admissions from the
teacher saying we want to teach it and
if you oppose it
you are the or the bigot and the phobe
and the ist
but the accusation is exactly what they
are doing themselves
walter since i'm guessing we all agree
that she's lying here what do we do
about all of the liars that it seems
like almost
everyone in charge of everything
important right now
is an abject liar and i always quote
that alexander sultan it's in quote
they know they're lying we know they're
lying they know we know they're lying
and they continue to lie
it's like there's no shame there's
nothing we can do to shame her
she's not going to stop well first of
all in her case
america needs to see more of her because
because she is everything that every
child
grows up hating about public school
teachers
she's pedantic smug she talks down to
people
she pretends that she's you know
infallible when you can
see right through half of her things
she's not logically consistent
we need the liars especially when
they're as bad as heard just keep lying
because this tactic of denying that
something exists
always breeds a very obvious counter
move proving that it does
and it's a very easy thing to do
and so as if they're gonna go with this
you know
it's not happening what you know it's do
you see any uh
monster in the room here while it stands
over their shoulder
they're gonna lose walter i got a title
for your next book well you just came up
with it yourself but just keep lying
like to me that's yeah maybe that's the
meme that we need to be pushing for all
these people instead of keep calling
them liars it's yeah
keep lying guys keep lying uh listen i
appreciate the three you joining me
have a good weekend guys i'm sorry we
didn't have more time we're on a little
bit of a crunch today and of course i
will have you guys all back
and for everybody else uh i hope you
enjoyed our round table this weekend
it's uh we skipped last weekend because
i was traveling and
this was actually a pretape technically
right now this is thursday for me
but i'm in miami right now for some
business with locals
uh as always i hope you have a great
weekend i hope that what we did
this week on the show gave you a little
something to think about didn't
make you completely bananas and perhaps
sparked some conversation that you can
now have with
someone in your family or a friend or
even on that
evil facebook or that crazy twitter
where you can go oh you know actually
what you're seeing on msnbc or what
you're seeing
out of this administration is not true
there are some
other uh people talking about things in
a way that perhaps
you should engage with instead of just
thinking that everyone that you disagree
with is big and racist and everything
else
on that note have a great weekend
everybody and i will
see you on monday